our subject faithful unto death
we know not wither thou goest and how
can we know the way
jesus said unto him i am the way
the truth and the life no man cometh
unto the father but by me
if he had known me you should have known
my father also
and from henceforth you know him
and have seen him
philip says unto him lord show us the
father and it sufficeth us
jesus said unto him
have i been so long time with you and
yet hast thou not known me philip
he that have seen me
have seen the father and how says thou
then
show us the father
thank god again for another opportunity
to worship him in spirit and in truth
there are many
so-called christians who worship god so
they think in spirit
but without the truth
it is impossible to worship god
acceptably unless he's worshiped in
spirit
and in truth jesus prayed in john 14 16
and i will pray the father he told the
disciples that i will pray the father
and he shall give you another comforter
that he may abide with you forever even
the spirit of truth whom the world
cannot receive
because he sees him not neither knoweth
him but ye know him for he dwelleth with
you and shall be in you he is the spirit
of truth
and so in worshiping god if there isn't
truth whatever spirit is present is not
the spirit of god
let me say that again
where god is presumably worship
and there's a lot of spirit and i put
spirit in quotation mark if truth is
absent
that spirit is not the spirit of god it
may generate a lot of noise a lot of
heat a lot of physical display and
commotion and promotion but
in the absence of truth
that spirit is not the spirit of god
when the worshipers of baal and mount
carmel in first kings 18 they were
worshiping they were crying out they
were worshiping they were possessed by a
spirit it was not the spirit of god the
spirit of god was with one man elijah
not with the 800 plus priests that were
carrying on a display you could not
imagine
god bless you thank you for joining us
again
i was hoping that uh
you listen very carefully to the words
god spoke through evangelist obutu
we are facing very very serious times
and all that he said deserves careful
consideration
this world is close to coming to an end
but the end will be catastrophic the end
will be more terrible than anything you
and i can possibly imagine
and it behooves you and me to understand
thus saith the lord that we might be
ready to face the times that are about
to break upon us
my subject for today is faithful unto
death
faithful unto death for those of you who
are not 70 evidence thank you very much
for joining us god bless you and i mean
it when i say
god bless you we appreciate and are
honored by your presence among us
little boys and little girls are
listening god bless you in a doubly
powerful way and let me remind you again
jesus wants you at your young age to
give your life to him
wherever you are god bless you god bless
your country particularly the host
country of kenya may the lord guide the
minds of those leaders at the national
level at the regional level the
provincial level the state level you
name it may the lord guide the leaders
that his gospel may go forward
i will ask you to do three little favors
for me then i'll jump into the message
number one is always
preserve reverence where you are
god is god seven days a week he never
ceases to be holy of course if you're
suddenly evidence the sun has set where
you are in kenya and so the holy day has
passed but you're still supposed to be
holy even on unholy days of secular days
preserve reference and god will bless
you favor number two pray for me while i
speak this final time
simply ask god to put his words in my
mouth jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then
the lord put forth his hand
and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i
have put my words in thy mouth
that's what i want
because the words of god will transform
your life in a way that will amaze you
and those who know you
favor number three
think
as you listen
come now
let us reason together said the lord
isaiah 1 18 let us pray
our father
we've come to the final day of these
presentations
we thank you for truth
and it's liberating effect on the mind
of those who receive it honestly
we thank you for decisions that have
been made their god
we thank you for the powerful
presentations you gave to your
evangelist
we thank you for the prayers of the
young people
they're singing
their ability to organize with limited
resources
we thank you for all who listen and are
listening
father help us to believe that through
your spirit the effects of this week of
presentations will extend far beyond
what we may now imagine
forgive me if i have sinned against you
or anyone listening
cleanse us dear god
that your spirit may do the work of
revealing truth
put your words in my mouth father put
ideas in my mind
and the spirit of christ in my heart i
pray for those who are not sitting there
and just
open their eyes they go out of love
because you love them
and show them what you will have them to
do
move them to god to make the right
decision and the right decision under
all circumstances is to accept thus said
the lord regardless of opposition from
friends or family
bless the little children their god give
them a consciousness of your presence
with them and for those who are sick
healed in god particularly those with
the burden of calling 19 remove that
condition father give them robust health
i pray
as i always say father bless the leaders
of the countries guide their minds guide
their deliberations now father
tighten your grip on my faculties
possess me absolutely i pray
use me as your loudspeaker i give you
full control
in jesus name we pray
amen
our subject faithful unto death
now revelation chapter 2 verse 10 the
angel told john to write to the church
of smyrna one of two churches that
received no rebuke from christ in those
seven letters to seven churches of the
seven two refused to receive no review
smyrna and philadelphia smyrna church
number two philadelphia church number
six and to smyrna even though they
received no rebuke the message still
came be thou faithful unto death
what does that mean
the highest sacrifice a person shall
make is the sacrifice of the life in
military terms it's called the supreme
sacrifice you give your life for your
country
christ told that church
be thou faithful unto death
that church no longer exists physically
but that message is for us for me and
for you be thou
faithful unto death in that statement we
see continuity
not be thou faithful like a flesh of
lightning that's in the sky and it's
gone
faithful unto death is like a lightning
that doesn't flash it just burns and
burns and burns and burns faithful unto
death calls for us to be persistent
moment by moment regardless of the
opposing forces and the threats the
enemy may place our way be thou faithful
unto death and while you're hearing my
words perhaps they're not having the
impact they should the bible is not
joking when it tells us we must be ready
to die for truth
in john 3 16 the bible says for god so
loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son that whosoever believeth in
him should not perish but have
everlasting life jesus christ died that
you and i might have an opportunity to
live if we accept that sacrifice
in first john chapter 3 verse 16 very
similar we go from john 3 16 to 1st john
chapter 3 6
chapter 3 verse 16 the bible said hereby
perceive with the love of god
because he laid down his life for us
and we ought to lay down our lives for
the brethren
our relationship with god
requires if necessary that we literally
die for truth
die for christ
as verily as he died for us
one good turn deserves another in first
john chapter 5 verse 19 chapter 4 verse
19 the bible says we love him
because he first loved us so we have two
expressions of love we love him because
he loved us first now how did he show
his love he died for us how are we
required to show our love we must be
willing to die for him and for his truth
be thou faithful
unto death
you are the average church and everyone
loves jesus the average christian church
if you were to say how many of you love
jesus hands go up some people may put up
two hands
subject that person to a test
and that's the only way you will know
the strength of that verbal declaration
i love jesus
the proof of god's love was the death of
christ the proof of our love must first
be the death of self
then if necessary the death of the body
for the sake of christ now i want you to
go with me to luke chapter 22.
we will read from verse 31 to verse 33
and tell me if you can identify with the
persons or the person peter in that
passage
luke 22
reading from verse 31
let me pray again father continue to be
with me you guys direct speak through me
please in the name of christ i pray amen
now the lord said
as luke 22 31 simon
simon
behold satan hath desire to have you
that he may sift you as we he wants to
shake you to see what he can shake out
of you
next verse but i have prayed for thee
that thy faith
fail not now you take fail not that's a
negative expression you turn it around
and make it positive and is saying i
have prayed that your faith will remain
constant
that's faithfulness jesus said i have
prayed that you will remain
faithful that's the same thing as i have
prayed for thee that thy faith fail not
i want you to stay strong since jesus
christ because christ knew what his
disciples would face here is it this is
christ who was also god imagine
god praying for you
that prayer of christ had to be answered
i have prayed for thee
that thy faith will not
and when thou had converted
strengthened thy brethren
now take a deep breath and read verse 33
and he said unto him
lord
i am ready
to go with thee
both into prison
and to death
don't let anyone distract you listen to
the bible
listen to peter and when peter spoke i'm
sure he meant what he said not knowing
his true condition
lord
i am ready right now
if you're ready it means now
to go with me
both into prison
and to death
of course christ had to tell him
that you'll deny me three times which he
didn't believe until he did it later on
in that chapter i think verses 57 58 and
16. he said i don't know him now
many of us we say i love jesus
and jesus says fine
let me test it
and when the test comes we are as
unreliable and as faithless as was peter
but we speak as confidently as peter did
lord i am ready
to go with me
into prison both into prison and to
death
an increasing level of severity i'm
willing to go to prison now that's not
enough
if necessary to die
and so peter goes from
one level to another level of spoken
simplity just from the lips now jesus
complained this people honoreth me with
their lips but their hearts are far from
me
peter
meant what he said
he fell down
of course he cried bitterly and
according to christ in verse 32 of luke
20 22 when he was converted he did
indeed strengthen the brethren because
something changed in his life but at the
point he spoke so boldly and brashly and
and rashfordly he did not realize he did
not have the foundation necessary to
carry out the words he had so
ill-advisedly spoken my question to you
for me is are we like peter we say lord
i'll be faithful no matter what
i'm going to the university of uh
technical university of ambassador and i
just set an exam on travel i'm not
taking it then you come to your final
year you have one more exam today it's
ensemble
i like peter you say i don't know i
don't know him i don't know him i need
this degree to guarantee my life and you
do it or whatever other test comes to us
someone sent me
a message sometime
i have lost my job
pray for me that i will be faithful to
god
in other words i will not accept any
offers of employment that requires
sabbath work
faithful unto death
when
john described those will be alive
in the very very last days on the earth
go with me to revelation 14.
john is describing at the direction of
the spirit of christ john is describing
the spiritual condition of those on the
earth who will be absolutely faithful to
god when all that the evangelist talked
about comes to full fruition and the
world is in a terrible condition such as
has never been seen here is how the
bible describes the those who are
faithful to god on the earth
and in the amount of revelation 14 verse
and in their mouth was found no guile
for they are without fault
before the throne of god
in their mouth was found no guile for
there without fault before the throne of
god
they also described that these are there
which were not defined with women for
their virgins
these are there which follow the lamb
with us or ever he goes
from verses three and four they follow
the lamb of revelation 14 wither
whatsoever he goes now what does that
mean it does not mean moving one foot
ahead of the other it leaves they were
willing to do whatever christ said
they were willing to follow the lamb
wither so ever he goeth whatever he says
i will do wherever he leads i will go
regardless of the opposition i may face
this is the mindset that is required to
survive the time of trouble that is
coming
god has to test the profession of faith
the procession of faith comes from the
lips and it is easy
and so baptismal candidates stand before
the church and they say i believe the
bible is god's word yes and they raise
their hands i'm the head of it or the
pastor says do you believe that the the
christ has come again
i believe they believe in returning a
tithe i believe and everyone believes
the church says
uh the pastor says where's the emotion
someone says i so move is there second i
second there's a third and a fourth are
you ready for the question ready for the
question all in favor and the whole
shirts in favor and people are accepted
into membership
that's for the month
now god says let me test that
let me test it
or someone stands at an altar
in front of a preacher with a a an
audience witnesses and with heaven
watching
he says do you take this woman to be a
lawful wedded wife in sickness and
health poor or riches and good weather
bad weather snow or heat whatever it is
and the man says yes
and heaven hears him earth is it
then the lady gets an accident she's in
the wheels here
and he puts in a nursing home
the test cannot take or he finds
somebody else or she finds somebody else
all professions of faith
must be tested
let us go now to genesis 22 we'll read
from verse 5 and look at the the uh
the test of faith let me put it that way
the test of fail the test of faith
genesis 22 reading from verse one let me
pray father as i continue as i move to
this section of the message continue to
speak right through me i pray for your
glory and the blessing of your people in
jesus name amen genesis 22 reading from
verse one
have that the bible says and it came to
pass after these things that god did
test abraham and said in him abraham and
he said behold here i am and he said
take now thy son thine only son isaac
whom thou lovest and get thee into the
mountain moriah and offer him for a
burnt offering upon one of the mountains
which i will tell the elf now
let me go back to verse 1 of verse 2
take now thy son
isaac
thine only son will love us
now surely god can count
god is the source of math god is the
source of all knowledge except crime of
course that came from satan
god knew abraham had two sons his first
son was born in chapter 16 to hagar
he was about 14 years old when isaac was
actually born so when god told abraham
take isa isaac was about 17 18 ishmael
was probably 31 32.
but god says
take now thy son isaac thy only son whom
thou love it god recognized in the
context of the plan of salvation in the
context of the covenant god recognized
isaac because isaac was a son of faith
ishmael was the son of works but god
still of ishmael don't misunderstand me
and god told abraham in genesis 17 he
would bless ishmael but his covenant was
with isaac because isaac was the result
of faith isaac was a result of abraham
passing a test
in john genesis 15 when god told abraham
your children would be like the stars of
heaven abraham believed that even though
his wife was barren now so god tells
abraham take isaac
and kill him as an offering
that's the test
take isa
and kill him
now it would have been easier for
abraham to kill himself than to kill
isaac i've been told by numerous parents
or people parents prefer to die than
bury their children
abraham would have gladly died in
isaac's place the test was so severe but
god told abraham sacrifice isaac
and abraham did all that was necessary
heroes very next morning after that
vision he took isaac they went off and
they came to the place which god had
told him of and abraham built and
altered their verse 9 of genesis 22 and
laid the wood in order bound isaac his
son and put him on the wood on the altar
and abraham stretched forth his hand and
took the knife to slay his son
and the eighth old lord called him out
of heaven saying abraham abraham and he
said behold here am i and he said lay
not thy hand upon the lad neither do
thou anything unto him for now
i know
now fear is gone
i have put you to the test and now
i know you will go to any light to obey
me
even to the degree of sacrificing what
is most precious to you and what was
most precious to abraham was isaac
god said
no need to kill him physically
you've killed him in your heart
and so we read in hebrews 11 verse 17 by
faith abraham when he was tried offered
up isaac and he that had received the
promises offered up his only begotten
son it is recorded as if abraham
literally did it because it was done in
his heart and god wants not is he in
your heart to be faithful to god even
unto death even if you do not receive
that degree you will not attend classes
not take exams on saturday even if you
live on the streets you will not work on
saddle abraham was willing to kill isaac
to demonstrate his faithfulness to god
and our subject his faithfulness be thou
faithful unto death this is no joke
the bible says for my grace i saved
through faith
we're saved by
faith we are judged by works
let me say that again
slowly
we are saved
by grace
through faith ephesians 2 verse 8
we're judged by words behold i come
quickly and my reward is with me to give
every man according as his work shall be
judgment looks at how
what we have done how we have lived to
see if how we have lived corresponded to
what we said
and so when god
puts us to the test
he wants to show us because he knows
the the is that profession truly worth
anything when you stood and you said i
will keep the sabbath when you said i
will do this i will do that i will do
that what was this was that made of
solid gold or egg and struggle at grass
let me say it again
daniel 12 1
there is coming a time of trouble on the
earth
such as the world has never seen
if that's the case
god needs people on the earth
with a faith
and a submission to him such as the
world has never seen and god has had
that periodically down through the
centuries you look at the three hebrew
boys in daniel chapter three they were
facing a fiery furnace they were
committed to their god they had passed
the test in chapter one refusing to eat
unclean foods at the risk of losing
their lives and they took the risk and
they passed the test god tested them
again in chapter three with the fiery
furnace
and they were willing to die again
daniel was also tested in chapter one
along with the three the test of diet
his life was at risk
he was tested again in chapter six when
a law was passed or all people should
pray to darius for 30 days and daniel
said no the punishment was to be thrown
in the lion's den then it was actually
thrown god saved his life the three
hebrew boys were actually thrown in the
fire god saved them but they had said
even if he does not save us
we're not bowing to that image they were
faithful
unto death
they accepted death in the heart
even though god did not allow them to be
physically burned or did not allow
daniel to be consumed by lion they were
willing to die
this is the commitment god needs he has
always needed by the way but
particularly in these last days when the
condition of the world will be so
horrible such as no one at any time in
europe's history has ever witnessed
that was uh
when i was a little boy
i had an injection for some reason
and i saw the needle you know when you
go to the dentist and he has or she has
to use a needle they tell you close your
eyes so you don't see the needle is two
feet long and they're gonna stick that
thing up in your jaws they don't want
you to see it because the expectation
you will expect suffering when there's
none
the expectation of that needle going
into your the nursery you begin to feel
pain before anything happens and so they
tell you close your eyes
so i close my eyes i'm a tough guy i
close my eyes and put my hands in the
hand my life in the hands of the lord
now when he actually speaks it is not as
horrible as we anticipate but let me
tell you something the pain that's
coming very soon is far worse than you
and i can ever anticipate
and to survive it
we need a faith
that is unafraid of death
and so god told abraham
sacrifice i see
and abraham said yes
and god said now i know
that you're willing that you fear me
that i mean more to you than anything
else
more than your son isaac whom you love
more than sarah who perhaps didn't even
know where abraham had gone more than
anything else more than your possessions
i am numero uno number one in your life
this is what god wants from us and let
me say it again every profession has to
be tested
many years ago
i was leading a little church
in michigan close to detroit
and assisting me was a retired minister
a powerful man in the lord
and he told me a story i've told several
times perhaps you've heard it perhaps
not anyway when he was a young man he
was married he had i think two children
two boys he couldn't find work that did
not require sabbath work so he was at
home his wife would work as a domestic
in people's homes washing their clothes
cleaning the kitchens whatever and she
could get sabbath and one day he was at
home with his two little boys
and he looked at them and he was talking
to god the wife was off working he's
unemployed
and he said to god and he told me this
he was about 88 90 when he was telling
this
but a kind of a power came over him and
he said he said i was keep i looked at
my two sides
and i said to god
i will watch those two little boys
starve to death. before i work himself
when he said that i can see the veins
popping in his neck and because he was
sorry he said i will watch those two
little boys
starve to death
before i work on sabbath god watched
jesus die rather than let us be lost
without any means of salvation god
watched jesus lead in gethsemane through
the scale he watched him beaten by the
roman soldiers he watched him crucify
the near he watched it he let it happen
why because of love for you
when that minister said that to me i
said my my my
do i have that kind of faith
i'm talking to many of you who are
college students so let me
deal with the college environment
are you willing to lose that degree
in order to be faithful to god
you're in a relationship you should not
be in
are you willing to bring it up
in order to be faithful to god
i was in a
somewhere on the face of the earth and
this lady came to me
she said i'm in a relationship with
someone outside of the church
i said okay you gotta break it up
she said i've been with him three years
i said yes let me repeat my words you
have to break it off
she said well i don't know how to do
that i would hurt him
i said you have a choice you can hurt
god or hurt him pick one
sometimes you have to be blood pick one
her god over him choose one
and she said okay well the story ended
up she finally broke it off but she said
something that many people need to
understand or say
i don't want to hurt him
the choice is you heard him or you heard
god choose one god did not want to hurt
you so he allowed jesus to be hurt on
calvary and in gethsemane and during his
life let me say it again in order to
spread you and me from absolute hurt god
put it on jesus
god had a choice
you know jesus said my god my god why
has thou forsaken me god had a choice to
save jesus or forsake us he for surprise
for a while
when jesus said if thou be willing to
remove this cup from me when he was
bleeding through his skin god had a
choice get him out of that and put us in
it god left him in it to save us
the bible says for god so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
the first could have said for god so
loved his son he gave up the world
and so when you're thinking well i don't
want to hurt him but god allowed jesus
to be hurt in order to save you and so
your choice must be spare god the pain
let someone else feel
whatever the decision may be
i won't take that job i won't do this i
won't do that why because i want to be
faithful unto death but
no one comes automatically to that level
of faithfulness the bible tells us how
it is developed let's go to luke 16 our
subject faithful unto death luke 16 how
does one come to that position of
faithfulness to god
where he or she will face death without
blinking
luke 16 before we read the first let's
pray father as i continue restrain me
restrain my carnal nature let truth flow
from me for your glory i pray and the
blessing of your people in jesus name
amen
listen carefully to a biblical principle
it applies in the church outside the
church in secular events whatever it
applies at every level of human
interaction
luke 16 10
he that is faithful in that which is
least
is faithful also in much
what does that mean that which is least
the little challenges have come our way
from day to day
jesus tells us be faithful in them
if you are faithful in them if i am
faithful in them i will develop the
habit of faithfulness and habits are
difficult to break good or bad let me
say it again habits good or bad are
difficult to break
so jesus says develop the habit of
faithfulness how the little challenges
that come our way from day to day where
we compromise and we say well that's
just a little thing god doesn't mind yes
he minds
he that is faithfully that which is
least
is faithful also in much
christ calls upon us develop the
capacity develop that capacity develop
that mindset that is willing to face
their how by being faithful in little
things day by day day by day
the universe
or that part of the galaxy that's
connected to this world and this world
was not made or were not made in a day
six days
day by day by day by day finally we have
this massive universe and this round
earth that spins and spins although some
people think it is flat
apply that spiritually
day by day by day by day you and i are
faithful and as we remain faithful by
the sustaining power of christ we will
eventually come to the place where we
each one of us is a little world of
absolute faithfulness to god that
nothing can alter reduce or change
one day at a time
we talked about the people who will be
faithful to god in the last days
revelation 14 3 to 5. listen to what
jesus tells you and me let's go to
matthew 24 we'll read verse 13 our
subject faithful unto death matthew 24
reading verse 13
but he that shall endure unto the end
the same shall be saved
now endure unto the earth
as i said earlier a commitment to christ
is not a flash of lightning it comes and
it's gone
a commitment to christ is a sustained
flash if there's such a thing it flashes
and it stays and it stays as a matter of
fact it gets brighter and brighter and
brighter this is what god wants he that
shall endure to the end not all people
endure to the end if you read ii timothy
chapter 4 verse 9 and verse 10 second
timothy chapter 4 verse 9 and verse 10
listen to what paul had to say about one
of his disciples
he said do thy diligence to come shortly
unto me for demons have forsaken me
having loved this present world and is
departed at the thessalonica there was a
disciple of paul called the mass who
worked with paul at some point demas
ceased to be faithful and he left paul
went off into the world
he did not remain
he did not endure
until the end
listen to jesus praying in john 17 verse
john 17 verse 12 i'll let you get a
couple of seconds to find john 17 12 as
you come from second timothy chapter
four john 17 verse 12 christ is praying
listen to what he says
while i was with them in the world i
kept them in thy name
those that thou gives me i have kept and
none of them is lost but the son of
perdition that the scripture might be
fulfilled judas walked with christ for a
while and then he left him
he did not remain faithful unto death
even though he was that close to christ
let's go to john chapter 8.
you know jesus said eat my flesh drink
my blood verse 53 verse 54 56 eat my
blood my flesh drink my blood some
disciples could not understand what he
was saying or they did not like what he
was saying
and in verse 66 the bible says from that
time many of his disciples went back and
walked no more with him many many of the
disciples of christ left him because
they did not like what he said they did
not endure unto the end
let me say again a profession of faith
cannot be simply a flash of lightning
that brights up the dark sky and then
it's gone as we call it in the western
world that's where you are a flash in
the pan
someone is supposed to be an entertainer
makes one song that's a hit never makes
another one the person becomes a one hit
wonder this is not what is required for
a place in god's kingdom we must be
faithful unto death and so judas left
all those disciples left they left in
such numbers that jesus turned to the 12
in verse 67 of john 6 of john 6 and said
will he also go away they were leaving
in such numbers we must be faithful unto
death
in other words the faithfulness of
christ
are there moments of stumbling yes are
they moments of weakness yes
in the garden as christ suffered he
prayed three times father if thou be
willing remove the three time because he
was suffering
and so jesus will understand if you
waver from time to time
but he cannot condone if we leave him
completely he can understand a weakness
he can understand a stumble he can
understand a fall and get up righteous
man follows seven times and guess that
he understands that he will not
understand a total abandoning of him
be thou faithful unto death follow jesus
what does it mean to follow jesus or let
me
come at it from a different perspective
go to john 15.
john chapter 15 lovely chapter it's four
minutes to nine where you are four
minutes to one where yeah i'll go a few
minutes beyond my time if you don't mind
john 15
we'll read from verse one
our subject faithful unto death we're
looking at the key to faithfulness the
key to spiritual strength and power
john 15 reading from verse 1
i am the true vine
and my father is the husband man
every branch in me that bears fruit not
fruit he taketh away and every branch
that bears food he purchased it that it
may bring forth more fruit now you're
clean through the word which i have
spoken unto you
abide in me
and i in you
as the branch cannot be fruit of itself
except it abide in the vine no more can
ye except he abide in me
i am the vine here the branches he that
abideth in me and i in him the same
bringeth forth but fruit for without me
he can do nothing if a man abide not in
me his camp forth as a branch and his
withered and men gather them and cast
them into the fire and they burn
if he abide in me and my words abide in
you you shall ask what he will and it
shall be done unto you hearing is my
father glorified that you bear much
fruit so shall ye be my disciples has
the father have loved me so have i loved
you continue ye in my love if ye keep my
commandments first then he shall abide
in my love even as i have kept my
father's commandments and abide in his
love stop
we will go over we review verses 4 to
10.
there is a word that occurs over
and over again and if you take a few
seconds to read verses 4 to 10 of john
15 you'll see that word it is the word
abide
it's translated continue in verse 9 it
is the same greek word meno to stay to
be consistent to remain and so the key
to being faithful is to remain connected
to jesus christ and so he tells us over
and over and over stay with me stay
connected
how do we do that
the study of the word
and of course prayer
and outreach
but mainly the study of the word
and prayer and so jesus says abide in me
verse four
and i in you
as the branch cannot bear fruit of
itself except it abide in the vine no
more can ye
except he abide in me he uses the symbol
of a branch attached to the main trunk
of the tree stay connected since jesus
christ without that there is no
possibility of remaining faithful to god
you cannot be safe for when you
disconnected from god you can speak it
it will never be a practical experience
in your life or mine
i am divine verse five here the branches
he that abideth in me and i in him the
same bringing forth much fruit for
without me he can do nothing if a man
abides not in me he's cast forth as a
branch
verse two cents every branch he made a
bear through not fruit he take it away
for six says if a man abide not in me
he's castle of the bread by the father
by the way
and men gather them and cast them into
the fire and they're burned
if he abide in me
and my words abide in you and when he
says my words he means himself because
christ is the word you shall ask what
you will it shall be done unto you
herein is my father glorified that ye
bear much fruit how does that happen by
abiding stay with christ we are called
to abide and the spirit produces the
fruits not you
you have to decide i have to decide to
abide that's my work it is the work of
the spirit to produce the fruit because
of our abiding let me say that again
you and i cannot produce the fruits of
the spirit if we did they wouldn't be
called the fruits of the spirit they'd
be called the fruits of humanity
they are the fruits of the spirit
because only the spirit can produce them
but in order for the spirit to produce
them according to the symbology of john
15 you and i the branches must be
attached to the main vine that's christ
so that whatever sustains christ
sustains us
verse 9
as the father hath loved me so if i
loved you continue
remain in my love how do you continue in
christ's love john 14 58 if you love me
keep my commandments he tells us in
verse 10 of john 15 how he remained in
the father's love let's read 9 and 10
again
as the father hath loved me so have i
loved you continue ye in my love that's
what you do you continue in my love then
he tells us how verse 10
if he keep my command
he shall abide or continue in my love
same greek word
even as i of the same way i have kept my
father's commandments and remain
continued in his love
i come to the point of god's
commandments as we talk about
faithfulness
the wages of sin is death and sin is a
transgression of the law first john 3 4.
so death comes at two ways
there's either death
for disobeying god's law
or the possibility of death for obeying
god's law let me explain that quickly
the death that comes from obeying god's
law is not the wages of sin
jesus died for being faithful to the
father paul had his head cut off to be
faithful to christ peter was crucified
upside down there was a disciple called
james who had his head removed from his
body why for obeying god
so that's death for obedience
then there's death for disobedience
that's not the death we want because
from that death there's no return but
when you lose your life for being
obedient to god you come back from that
you come back
we have to choose which death am i
prepared to take on
death as the punishment for sin which is
violation of god's law or death because
the world kills me for being faithful to
god let's choose that death i am willing
to die for god but not like peter we
must demonstrate that faithfulness in
the little things in our lives day by
day
the evangelist told us i believe there's
a great controversy based 688 paragraph
one
through the two great eras
the immortality of the soul
and sunday sacredness satan will bring
the people under his deceptions
the devil's plan is to deceive the world
and he is succeeding the bible tells us
in revelation 12 9 and the great dragon
was cast out that old serpent called the
devil and satan which deceiveth the
whole world of course accepts you he
deceiveth the whole world
the people running around in churches
and politicians whatever absolutely
deceived and not aware of it
presentations like these open people's
eyes people's eyes
first john 5 198 and we know that we are
of god and the whole world life in
wickedness this was the case in the days
of noah because when god was ready to
send a flirt only eight people walked
into that ark the rest of the world was
in darkness not because light was not
said but light was rejected and there's
a darkness and there's a darkness
the darkness there's a darkness that is
just the absence of light there's a
darkness that comes from the rejection
of light and that darkness is more dark
than the other darkness i'm not
confusing you
if the lightness is in you be darkness
how great is that darkness jesus tells
us rejection of light produces a
darkness that is deeper than just the
ignorance of light
let me say it again
the lord helped me
someone who honestly and innocently does
not know the seven days of sabbath
is in darkness because the biblical
light of that commandment has not come
to the person
someone who hears it
and rejects it is in deeper darkness
there's a deeper dark that's what i mean
rejection of light creates a darkness
that is deeper than the darkness of
innocent ignorance
and so first john 5 19 says we know that
we are of god
and the whole world i think what does it
mean to be of god go to john chapter 8
verse 47
he that is of god heareth god's words he
therefore hear them not because you're
not of god someone who's of god receives
the truth when it comes
let's put those two verses let me pray
father help me to make this simple then
i'll close help me god in jesus name i
pray amen go to first john 5 19 you have
10 seconds to find five seconds
you have it all right
king james version
and we know that we are of god
and the whole world life and darkness
meaning the whole world is not of god
simple reason now what does it need to
be of god
according to first john 5 98 we go to
the same author but in a different book
he wrote the gospel of john the one who
wrote the gospel of john wrote first
john 5 and uh he also wrote
second john 3 john revelation we go down
to john 8 47
he that is of god heareth god's words
he therefore hear them not because
you're not of god
question for you
have you been hearing god's words from
night to night
i don't need to be judgmental i don't
i'm just giving you the word sometimes
the word is blunt
he that is of god
heareth god to hear is not simply to use
this it is to respond from the heart
he that is of god
heareth
god's word heeds it or basically even
without understanding all the details
the little piece of truth that person
receives touches the heart strings and
the person responds he that is of god
heareth god's words
he therefore hears or not said christ to
the sight of the pharisees because
you're not of god
you're rejecting truth
because you're not of god
but you're in church
fearful unto death
my young brother my young sister
do not allow christ to come upon you as
a surprise
revelation 16 15 behold i come as a
thief
let christ not come as a thief to you
these presentations particularly the
evangelist presentation hopefully have
opened people's eyes
blessed with he that watches and keepeth
his garments unless he was naked and
they see his shame what are the garments
the righteousness of christ what is
righteousness obedience to the will of
god
then so i call upon you in the name of
jesus
follow christ
to follow christ
is to abide
if he says left go left
if he says a several day the seventh day
you know luke chapter 5 from verse 3
jesus sat on the board of peter and
preached a sermon when he was done he
told people let's go fishing
peter said lord
we've told all night and have taken
nothing
nevertheless as thy word i let down the
name
a very powerful statement
i'm a professional fisherman god jesus
you're a carpenter but you're a god if
you tell me go fishing i'll go but i
want you to know we were out all night
we got nothing but since you say go i'm
going
someone listening to me i have to say
father you told me to keep the sabbath
my great-grandfather was something else
my grandfather my cousins but they all
belong to another church on the sunday
or wednesday but since you have told me
through the word the seven days of
sabbath i'll do
that and when peter went fishing
according to the words of christ
he called so many fish another boat had
to come both boats began to sink there
were so many fear what a pleasant way to
sing under the blessings of god
to follow christ
is to abide stay with him let nothing
shake you from christ if you leave him
where you're going
if christ says i am life
listen to let's look at two verses
carefully another thought keeps saying
my clothes i'll close listen to two
verses hebrews 2 verse 14
for as much then as the part children
are partakers of flesh and blood he also
himself likewise departed the same that
through death he might destroy him that
had the power of death that is the devil
that doesn't have the power of death
he's the god of death
this is the jesus at the tomb of lazarus
i am the resurrection of the life
now the devil is death he brought sin
death came because of sin the devil has
a power of death
christ is life
when you leave christ
the only other place you can go is to
death
the deaths may come by drugs alcohol
whatever the only option you have when
you leave christ is to go to death but
death can be beautified because when the
devil tempted adam and eve in the garden
he said god does know that in the day
ether of then your eyes shall be opened
you shall be as gods knowing good and
evil he beautified disobedience he
beautified death he put a ribbon on it
it was gift package and eve accepted it
adam followed her
let me tell you something
a casket made of gold is still a cascade
there's a dead person in it
you can put flowers on the grave as much
as you like you cannot beautify death
you can beautify the cemetery not death
when you leave christ
you're going to death
when you come to christ you're coming to
life come to life
come to life
and say father i give my life to you
grant me the power moment
by moment to be faithful let me say it
again moment
by moment
hour by hour day by day week by week to
be faithful do not be like peter i am
ready now to go into prison unto death
and then he denied christ but of course
peter will be in the kingdom because he
changed
let us
give ourselves to christ accept him as
life
and ask him
sustain me
day by day
moment by moment yeah minute by minute
certainly only need a minute to ruin
your life
or 10 seconds
we remain faithful unto death
by being faithful in little things
let me say it again
there is a time of catastrophe coming on
this earth
such as the world has never seen it'll
be worse than the flood
worse than sodom and gomorrah
even in the flood they were evidence of
god's mercy
some parts of the earth had little
destruction others more destruction
based on the more sinful the area was
you read that in patriots and prophets
in the days of no a lot
a city was spared because lord said let
me go to that sea
this time
it'll be so terrible on this earth when
christ comes
there will be
absolutely
no mercy
that's why one of the messages
that must be spread is come out of her
my people
those churches
that mislead
and tell you the law has been done away
with and any day can be the sabbath you
need to get out of those churches
the greatest catastrophe in the bible
maybe the greatest is the destruction of
jerusalem why they rejected christ by
the rejected christ by rejecting truth
when you reject truth you reject the
giver of truth that is jesus christ and
even though they were god's people and
at least because they descended from
abraham
god sent the romans to destroy that city
the suffering was beyond the scale of
human understanding a church absolutely
destroyed by christ let me tell you
something one of the most dangerous
places to be is in the wrong church
i'm asking you
i believe through the spirit of god
come where god is obeyed come where his
law is honored honor it through the
power of jesus christ because the bible
says in first john 5 3
the law of god's commandments are not
grievous they are not hard
this is heart not the law ask god to
change this
that his law
my fine expression in our lives sinful
unto death i want you to make that
commitment but make it every day peter
made it once you and i must make it
father today
the 5th of february 2022
let me be willing to die for you if you
open your eyes tomorrow father let me
today the 6th of february
be faithful as you walk to your
classroom father as i sit in that
classroom in biology and listen to uh
evolution let me be faithful unto you
are you wherever you go fathers i go
where i'm going let me be faithful and
you constantly constantly
there is uh
those of you who make decisions and i
hope you're making decisions
there is a number
let me give it to you it is two five
four
seven 704
853 looks like
if i read that properly
you can text to whatsapp your uh but the
information will be given to you again
when i'm concluded
text your decision by whatsapp let us
know that you have made the intelligent
decision as a college student with a
mind brilliant mind to follow jesus
christ and to be faithful today and when
you make that decision as a father i am
making a decision to be baptized i am
making a decision to honor your sabbath
day i am making a decision to follow
truth and keep me faithful and grounded
in that decision remain faithful unto
death how he that is faithful in that
which is least
is faithful also
in much less bar heads as we pray father
in heaven we thank you for your word we
thank you lord for the challenge but we
thank you also for the reassurance that
we can be faithful through
constantly abiding in christ because by
abiding in him he gives us the power
that god help us to recognize those
things that seek to separate us from
christ to break that bond between us and
our savior bless those who listen father
there are young people under pressure
right now because they do not want to
disappoint their friends they may
hesitate to make a decision for jesus
christ help them to understand if they
make that decision they may inspire
their friends to accept jesus christ
father let no one be intimidated by
circumstances let decisions be made for
you right this very moment as i pray
also among the little children who are
watching their god bless those who
listen give them courage to choose truth
to choose christ to choose to obey that
they might be faithful unto death and
keep them ever conscious of the fact
that there is a trouble coming on this
earth not far down the road such as the
world has never seen it will usher in
the return of jesus christ bless all the
students bless their studies provide
their tuition bless the families that
sacrifice to send them to college their
god and as i always pray help them to
determine how they will use that
education for the glory of the savior
who gave them the brilliant minds that
they have heal the sick i pray father
save us when you come without losing one
continue to bless the youth who organize
this meeting in jesus name we pray
amen
thank you very much pastor
i believe that is supposed
to i'm looking for one that will sound
fair it is supposed to radicalize each
one of us
not the radicalization that we see the
government mentioning or the one
avengers arnold
spoke of but make us have that resolve
that can make us
be willing to take death as pastor has
stayed
it is my challenge which one of us that
we shall listen and we shall
every day seek
to honor god and seek to pay the
ultimate sacrifice if that
is to be so
if that is to be so so we this marks the
end of the main virtual gospel campaign
in february 2022 it has been the most or
the largest week i believe to most of us
where we've come to the reality of the
truth in the word of god in the deepest
sense that we never even expected
personally i never expected that what i
have learned
i would learn
back in my mind i knew this was outreach
i've been to various missions
and
the mind was focused to outreach those
who understand the word
know what i could be meaning
but i came to the realization that it
was meant for me i've come to the
realization that this was purely for me
and i am very much grateful to god
very much grateful to god so these are
as we are crowning the whole program
i will have just a few people say a word
of thank you
as uh i never informed you that
the memo tombstone media evangelism
menace is run by students from technical
university of mumbasa
currently they are their attachments
spread across the country
but we had a few who managed to share
the hours of thank you listen
we have a lot of thank you from a couple
of us
let the technical team share that
go through
for honoring our request to spare the
team mission the honor to go through
for honoring our request to spread the
truman mission
god has used through in a mighty way to
unpack unto us different studies that
point us to christ
their words have impacted us positively
in different capacities
may god strengthen us as we journey on
thank you
hello my name is brian ortino kidanda
a member of timon and this is a thank
you to the what's happening i'm supposed
to hear you and jesus christ
may god's strength acceptance
thank you in this virtual gospel
campaign and do for the wonderful
messages that god has spoken to us
through you
thank you and thank you and may god
bless you so much
[Music]
hello i am cedric emmanuel i'm the team
cheer person
i thank god for the tremendous virtual
gospel campaign and the work is doing to
our speakers
may god bless you all
[Music]
hello
i'm joseph
[Music]
a devoted one
you've actually spoken to god himself
thank you may god bless you
shalom
hello
i'm nora skelgora
i'm the team mtf editor and i've been
the chair of this gospel campaign i
would like to take you this opportunity
to thank god for leading us through the
campaign and also to thank our pastor
randy
and evangelist arnold for leading us
through the campaign
my prayer for thee is that may god bless
thee
keep thee make his festion upon thee and
be gracious unto thee
[Music]
amen
and i believe
this platform
and if it is
thank you
is
good evening everyone everyone
but our
youth youth plan
for it and
our church is chatting
to uh worshipers worshipers of god in
this areas area
and
with their leadership leadership
it was
um
[Music]
uh
um
shall be shall be
[Music]
otherwise otherwise god bless god bless
you may god bless you guys
i want to
talk to you talk to you those are given
their lives you are coming coming
how are you
lucky
because
he has been squeezing his times
is
thank you so much and it has been such a
blessing to be with you all
and
the final message was a fitting one
that
be faithful and to the end
and so my prayer for us is heba near let
him hear what the spirit said unto the
churches
and may god keep us
um for eternity shall reveal
our faithfulness now so
god bless you and let us not be willing
well doing for induces and we shall reap
if we faint not thank you
thank you very much evangelists
for being using use
for being used by
you will also remember to pray for this
person
who is withdrawn
is
pasta thank you very much my closing
remarks are simple historical sketches
page 285 paragraph four
historical sketches page 285 paragraph
four i'm speaking particularly to the
youth every youth should be impressed
with the fact
that he's not his own
that his strength his time his talents
belong to god
it should be his chief purpose in life
to glorify god and to do good unto his
fellow man historical sketches page 285
paragraph four and sign courage the
young people who organized and those who
listened and not disregarding others but
particularly the youth that god is
dependent heavily upon you ecclesiastes
12 1 remember now thy creator in the
days of thy youth the young people who
are organized therefore it has the same
opposition disregarding
you in the days of your lives
is
bless that person
bless
continue to use your man's servant
evangelist obutu continue to put words
in her mouth that the messages he
declares may bring others to the point
of readiness hear this humble pray
father save us when you come i pray
until then keep us faithful in all we do
in jesus name amen
you